you know was after Thanksgiving prep
last year and my chef Chris Lim he gets
very excited when he has these ideas and
he kind of just smacked me on the back
we kind of looked me in the eyes and
said yo what about turkey under
cinderblock
you know we've all kind of looked at
each other and what can we do to make
this more fun and you know we're gonna
do a play on our classic dish chicken
under a brick we're just gonna do a
turkey under a cinderblock
you're first gonna get rid of the
wishbone then we're gonna take off the
breasts and then in the same motion
you're gonna take the leg and the thigh
off with the breast and the wing intact
we'll season the flesh with salt black
pepper and a little bit of lemon zest
and then when you flip it over the skin
we only season with salt this is where
you get the pen smoking hot just with a
little bit of canola oil and you really
gotta wait for that smoke because when
you put this 16 pound bird into this pan
the temperatures gonna drop and you're
gonna add each side of the bird skin
side down and then you're gonna almost
kind of interlock them so that it's one
solid piece and then once you do that
very very very carefully you're gonna
take a cinder block wrapped in aluminum
foil and you're gonna kind of press it
down so that you put it at an angle
where it's actually pressing down the
breasts to thighs breasts and at this
point you want to leave it on the heat
until you start to see the brown and
start to form around the edges but
that's when you go into a 500 degree
oven for about 20 to 25 minutes you know
now you're gonna take the turkey out of
the oven then take the cinder block
which is gonna be hot at this point take
it off put that aside and you just let
it sit on the heat until you know you
can check it every once in a while with
a spatula but you want to get like this
almost like glassy kind of skin on the
bottom and then we will flip the turkey
on to its flesh side just for 10 to 15
seconds like literally it's just like a
kiss you're just kind of sealing the
juices in and then we'll put it to that
resting rack and let it rest for 8 to 10
minutes we'll add the turkey back in
we'll throw in handfuls of chopped herbs
and fried herbs and autumn olives and
all this kind of stuff to get everything
nice and bubbly and beautiful and
presentation and then we're gonna take
spoonfuls of this and base the turkey
I'm gonna kind of put everything back
together hit it with fresh herbs and
bring it kind of up to a boil so it's
kind of like sizzling and then when you
bring it to the table you know you'll
have everything bubbling and
and the smell and all that kind of stuff
and bring it to the table hot serve it
in the in the pan that you cooked it in
and you let people get dirty so from all
of us here at restaurant Marc Forgione
Happy Thanksgiving hope to see you soon
and remember to have fun okay